رحب فيل برأيك في هذا
الحادث
على مقياس من واحد إلى عشرة من
قضايا الأمن القومي، وسأعطيه بأدب
عن اثنين، وهذا يوضح الكثير
عن عدم قدرة واشنطن
والكونغرس في البيت الأبيض على الحديث
عنه  قضايا الأمن القومي غير ذات أهمية نسبيًا
مقارنة بما هو عليه فيما يتعلق
بالاستخبارات، إذا أراد الصينيون
جمع صور لأمريكا، يمكنك الوصول إلى
Google Earth، يمكنك الحصول على
قمر صناعي سري صيني إذا أرادوا
اعتراض الاتصالات، فيمكنهم القيام بذلك
باستخدام الأقمار الصناعية، وأوافق على ذلك هناك
هي بعض المزايا التي يمكن أن يتمتع بها البالون
ولكن بالنسبة لريد، فقد التفنا
حول بالون لعدة أيام في واشنطن
العاصمة وألغى وزير الخارجية
الرحلة للحصول على منطاد، أعطني استراحة،
هذا اثنان على مقياس من واحد إلى عشرة،
نعم أنا كذلك  يذهلني هذا أيضًا
في الدار البيضاء، كما تعلم، لقد
صدمنا عندما اكتشفنا أن الصينيين
يتجسسون علينا،
ونحن نتجسس عليهم طوال الوقت،
ولدينا أكبر جهاز تجسس في
العالم،
كما تعلم أنه يجب أن يكون موجودًا  إن هذا يجعلني أعتقد
أن هناك
قضية أوسع نحتاج إلى الاعتراف بها، وهي أن
الصين هي ثاني أكبر اقتصاد في
العالم، وأنها سوف تتجسس علينا
بالطريقة التي تعلمون بها بصراحة أن الكثير من
البلدان الأخرى تعمل
بشكل جيد، وأعتقد أن ما نحتاج إلى الاعتراف به
هو أنه عادة في الماضي
تعود 20 30 40 50 عامًا عندما تتوقف
محادثاتهم في الكونجرس مع
سياسة البيت الأبيض عند الشواطئ،
ولا ينبغي أن تكون المحادثة هنا
حول تهديد محتمل للصين
يجب أن يكون مكتب التحقيقات الفيدرالي قادرًا على تقييمه مع
تم جمع هذا البالون ولكنني سأفاجأ
إذا كان الأمر حساسًا بشكل لا يصدق،
فيجب أن تكون المحادثة هي لماذا لا يستطيع
البيت الأبيض الجلوس مع الكونجرس لمدة
10 دقائق ويقول انظروا ماذا
سنفعل حيال هذا ولماذا لا يستطيع
البيت الأبيض ذلك  أقول ببساطة أننا
سنسقطها وهو ما كان من الممكن أن يفعلوه،
أود أن أقول شيئًا آخر لم
تتم مناقشته، هناك فرصة مثيرة للاهتمام وأنا
متأكد من أن الصينيين
لم يتوقعوها وهذه هي الطريقة التي
يمكنهم التفكير بها  المستقبل بشأن القيام
بأشياء مثل البالونات التي تشتت انتباه
أمريكا فيما يتعلق بقضايا الأمن القومي
أعتقد أنها فرصة مثيرة للاهتمام حقًا
للصينيين لتقييم
الرد السياسي الأمريكي للقراءة